the England Gambit traps this is a real
opening and if you haven't played it
definitely recommend it Bishop to E7 if
they continue with Bishop to F4 to hold
on this material then we're gonna play
Queen to B4 this is check also attacking
the bishop here on F4 Queen's gonna come
take on B2 and then the field move from
White's standpoint is Bishop C3 second
the queen can't take the Rook here on A1
it's defended by the Knight on B1 but
unfortunately it's gonna fail to Bishop
to B4 it's just no real good way for
white to continue if he tries to block
off with his Queen here could just take
with his Bishop Queen takes sure Queen's
gonna come up here that is going to be
checkmate